[Musik]
der kunde greift sich eine rote flasche
aus dem regal die kameras erkennen eine
rote fleisch und registrieren dass der
kunde das produkt behält die kameras
erkennen aber nicht genau das produkt
weil ein anderer kunde die sich
vielleicht das habe ich mich auch
gefragt dann wird gesehen oder der kunde
kauft erstens regelmäßig ketchup der
ketchup steht normalerweise genau an
dieser stelle das system für ketchup zum
warenkorb hinzu dh man wird praktisch
also man gibt noch mehr daten an amazon
und die wissen genau was man kauft und
was nicht also lebensmittel und alles
eines um wie gesagt man geht jetzt
einfach hier raus
[Musik]
und das war es auch schon weil da das
system wollen auch den fehler würde ich
mal sagen zwei kaffeepausen gibt es war
zugleich ein ich weiß nicht kann ich gar
nichts für so ist ja nicht mein stil ist
heute umsonst kriegt was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
ich glaube das ist auf jeden fall das
video in dem ich am um gepflegtesten
opfer das geht so einer kammer sieht man
immer gut aus leute und zwar heute unser
ja so gut wie letzter tag hier in new
york und ich habe nur noch überlegt das
habe ich auch oft in den kommentaren
gelesen dass wir diesem amazon co dingen
noch ein bisschen mehr auf die schlichte
gehen und ich davon einfach mal versuche
einen tag lang also einen tag lang nur
amazon bau solcher experimente habe ich
früher ja sehr sehr viel gemacht aber
irgendwann hat es dann keinen bock mehr
drauf ist auch nicht so der konnte nicht
unbedingt machen will aber hier mache
ich es auf jeden fall eine ausnahme weil
ich meine in deutschland haben wir
keinen amazon.de und ich weiß dass ich
sehr viele von euch dafür interessieren
wir werden da viele produkte testen
einmal zum frühstück natürlich mittags
und abends und dann auch schauen wie
teuer ist es eigentlich wobei das
natürlich auch von stadt zu stadt
unterschiedlich ist ich zeige euch dann
auch immer diese quittung und mails die
ich bekomme von den hier new york ist
alles teuer weswegen man das
wahrscheinlich nicht vergleichen kann
wenn ich das jetzt irgendwie in seattle
gibt es dann auch noch machen würde
aber gut das ist eine gute frage
wir werden schauen jetzt wird erstmal
los wir machen jetzt erstmal so eine
hafen tournee nicht haben tod habe tour
hathor entschuldigung habe zu walter
bereich und ja ich nehme euch halt noch
mal ein bisschen mit let's go daumen
nach oben aber den kanal abonniert
meinen neuen zweiten kanal und mache ihr
installiert
das geht so leute was geht ab wir haben
jetzt schon abend das problem ist wir
haben heute schon sehr viel erledigt
weswegen ich jetzt das erste mal
erstmals zum golf shop gehen konnte ich
konnte vorher nicht konnte ich nicht
zeitlich einrichten
auch aufgrund dieser beiden damen im
hintergrund und jetzt geht's los ich hab
lust und mal schauen was ich mir ziehen
kann
beim amazon shop ich nehme ich natürlich
mit und jetzt ist auch schon der aufzug
da ja ich komme also ich muss sagen ich
glaube mit dem wetter hatten wir auf
jeden fall glück es ist echt angenehm
warm doch ich lauf hier in bully und
ganz normale ernährung gewöhnt haben wir
dieser shop der ist einfach durchgehend
offen also rund um die uhr kannst du
darunter gebauten und wir müssen jetzt
gleich rechts und dann einfach nur
geradeaus und dann sind wir schon bei
amazon co store
also wir haben ja das passt da vorne
da fahren jetzt schon wieder der
mongolei und wir hier die blonde die hat
es noch gar nicht gesehen wie das was
hier eigentlich los oder wie das
funktioniert deswegen zeige ich dir das
jetzt mal du wirst fasziniert sein
ja ja die kennt man schon sehr bekannt
ja genau von koch ihr könnt leid und
nicht mit rein kommen weil nur eine
person darf offiziell oder erhalt wenn
ihr euch ein eigenes konto macht könnt
ihr auch ein
der junge
ja
[Musik]
so jetzt stellt sich natürlich die frage
was nehme ich mir es gibt auf jeden fall
in jedem was anderes also in jedem store
diese sachen habe ich jetzt nur noch gar
nicht gesehen
nudeln
das sicherlich aus
ich muss sagen ich habe auch noch nicht
so groß noah dieses zeug hier habe ich
noch nie gesehen das nämlich jetzt mit
barry matt und dann reichen wir das
eigentlich auch schon
ich habe mir noch so ein paar andere
sachen mitgenommen ja hier ist kann man
das sieht gesund aus
brauchen wir das geht vielleicht später
sonst noch mal hier rein
mal
das schon wieder
oder
sie hat jetzt verstanden wie das hier
überhaupt funktioniert also leute wenn
ihr einen job sucht die in amerika wo
man diese aber zum menschen
sie müssen eigentlich nichts machen
außer sitzt sie musik hören und ein
bisschen essen und da sind drei in einem
shop ganz verrückt und lesen auch dabei
ich hab noch nie so komisches wasser
trinken
[Musik]
man denkt es schmeckt es riecht es liegt
nach erdbeere aber es schmeckt nach
erdbeere das royale macht probieren
es ist echt wird
oha ganz komisch also dafür leute der
typ hat auch einmal zum titel das ist
ganz bekannt ist schon ein sehr
angesehenes und geschäftsmodell
nein der arbeitet noch nicht in
deutschland kennen wir das nicht wo ich
glaube das war's mit amazon gehört abend
wir haben uns jetzt doch noch dazu
entschieden hier eine pizza zu essen bei
little italy bis zum stadtteil in new
york haben so sagt man das also ich bin
dann natürlich ehrlich zu euch deutsche
dass ich vielleicht ja dass versuche
messen und ich durchzuziehen aber immer
ist es natürlich auch nicht möglich
wollen wir nur einmal in new york ist
das doch unser letzter tag könnt ihr
verstehen oder
sollte koningin de morgen aussieht
wusste new york new york ist ja heute
wir haben wieder geiles wetter in new
yorks gefühlt nur geiles wetter und für
mich geht es jetzt zum amazon co store
ich bin nämlich richtig gespannt bei
frühstück habe ich da mir noch nie
geholt ich denke mal dass es da dann ja
immer extra zum frühstück halt mehr
sachen gibt es gibt auch eine ganze
kaffee abteilungen
das heißt du kannst du deinen kaffee
machen wie auch immer das funktionieren
der wird auch automatisch auf deine
rechnung geschrieben dann bringe ich
noch was für marin etwas wünsche dir zum
frühstück irgendwas längeres und
eventuell auch noch ein bisschen mehr
genau das machen wir jetzt danach steht
nämlich noch eine kleine brotzeit
avancen monstertruck dahinter mir das
hier ganz normal also das wetter ist
echt wieder zu krank und da sind wir
auch schon wieder da ich bin zudem weil
es immer am nächsten
[Musik]
also irgendwie für mittagessen oder
abendessen ist es ein bisschen werk hier
alles muss ich sagen und halt auch am
steuer
leute ich habe gerade auch mal was
genommen und es dann wieder zurückgelegt
guck mal wer checkt also wahrscheinlich
schon aber sagen wir mal ich wollte so
irgendwas dies ist oder so
hier der kellogg's kellogg's co hat das
nehme ich mal mit vorsichtig okay das
sollte eigentlich reichen erstmal immer
gespannt wie teuer es wird
und wie gesagt man geht jetzt einfach
hier raus
[Musik]
und das war es auch schon weil
ganz entspannt und was auch kassels
leute hier brauchte ich meine
internetverbindung
damit das funktioniert also bei mir das
jetzt auch ohne funktioniert und ich bin
jetzt gleich mal auf die quittung
gespannt die ich ganz entspannt in der
app mir anschauen kann
vietoris war ich tippe auf jeden fall
auf mindestens 25 dollar
ist halt teuer hier ne leute also zum
frühstücken du kannst du dann kaffee
entspannt machen aber es gibt so nicht
dieses typische amerikanische frühstück
so nass und so keine ahnung warum werde
ich eigentlich gedacht dagegen nur da
gibt es irgendwie nur so gesunde sachen
okay leute wieder zurück im hotel
hier kann man es jetzt sehen zwei kaffee
orangensaft einmal dieses burrito dingen
oder was das ist dann die cornflakes und
cookie für insgesamt das hier ist jetzt
die amazon geb ich habe das schon fünf
einkäufe getätigt einmal hallo kannst
das mach schon danke einmal hier unten
512 items drei teams und jetzt gerade
wieder fünf items und es hat gekostet 17
dollar 44 für das ganze hier also schon
viel hier so ein cookie 375 alte der
humus welche web 6 dollar 99
jetzt ist mir etwas krasses aufgefallen
also ich habe einen kaffee umsonst wenn
ich jetzt voreilig jetzt verklagt oder
ist das vielleicht ein angebot
ich habe einmal ja diesen diese wette
das war so ein wettschießen jetzt habe
ich zurück gelegt dann habe ich das hier
genommen
das haben die auf jeden fall gecheckt
haben ja hier sehen aber in der app
steht nur einer 2 dollar 85 und wir
haben ja insgesamt auf 6 items und nicht
nur fünf von daher hat das system noch
einen fehler würde ich mal sagen also
leute zwei kaffee zum preis von einem
gau
ich weiß nicht habe kann ich gar nichts
mehr so ist ja nicht meine schuld
nicht umsonst gericht ohne scheiß diese
dinge habe ich früher immer gegessen hat
die so lange schon nicht mehr gesehen in
diesem bunten farben
leider haben wir keine milch deswegen
muss jetzt ein bisschen kaffee da rein
macht marie ist das okay aber wir muss
sagen
keine ahnung was da drin ist sagt aber
nein
[Musik]
1749 okay ich bin mittlerweile wieder zu
hause in deutschland angekommen habe
jetzt gerade erst mal war sieben stunden
geschlafen von 8 bis 14 uhr sechs schon
tschuldigung das video aber ich würde
nacht im flieger geschnitten wir sind
praktisch durch die nacht geflogen und
deswegen ist es jetzt schon fertig muss
noch das ende aufnehmen ich weiß ich
wollte eigentlich noch mehr sachen von
amazon protesten habe allerdings keine
zeit mehr gehabt weil wir dann auch zum
flughafen mussten und so das war ein
bisschen blöd ich hoffe dass es trotzdem
cool rüber gekommen und ich muss sagen
so ich bin mal gespannt wann das ganze
nach deutschland kommt und ob es
überhaupt nach deutschland kommt weil
das ist halt wirklich das ist einkaufen
der zukunft das ganz krass vor den
produkten die man dort kaufen konnte war
ich jetzt nicht nicht wirklich überzeugt
muss ich sagen also ich hab schon leben
gesehen wo es leckere sachen gibt die
haben so ein abteil da gibt es dann
amazon kitchen also wahrscheinlich ein
lebensmittelmarkt von amazon da wird
alles halt also heißt auf jeden fall
amazon kitchen da gab es zum beispiel
dieses sandwich was am anfang ganz nice
geschmeckt hat irgendwann dann einfach
nur noch nach blättern und auch sonst
nur diese frühstücks auswahl der
cappuccino ist habe ich ja auch ein
umsonst bekommen hat mich jetzt nicht
ganz überzeugt muss ich mal sagen
trotzdem sehr sehr interessant ich hoffe
euch hat es auch gefallen und abonniert
auf jeden fall den kanal instagram alex
wie wir sehen uns hier dann am sonntag
wieder um 19 uhr gibt es neues video ich
wollte jetzt immer so drei vier videos
die woche bringen